Transcriber: Nora Mahmoud
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Hayatta en çok kime güvenirsiniz?
Annenize, eşinize,
kardeşinize, çocukluk arkadaşınıza?
Peki hayatta en çok
güvendiğiniz bu kişiye,
bütün WhatsApp yazışmalarınızı
okutur muydunuz?
Ya da internette
girdiğiniz bütün siteleri,
yaptığınız bütün aramaları
gösterir miydiniz?
Sanırım cevap hepimiz için net.
Her bireyin, kendi kişisel alanında
mahremiyet ihtiyacı var
ve buna hakkı var.
Kişisel verilerin korunması,
yakın zamanda daha da
sıklıkla duyacağımız,
çok önemli bir kavram.
Kişisel veriler ve mahremiyetin korunması,
birçok ülke mevzuatına
göre bir insan hakkı.
Tarihe baktığımızda,
kişisel verilerin korunmasının
ve mahremiyetine ilişkin bazı ilkelerin
oldukça eskiye dayandığını görüyoruz.
Bunun en bilinen örneği,
milattan önce beşinci yüzyılda
uygulanmaya başlayan
Hekimin Sır Saklama Yükümlülüğü.
Bugün hâlâ geçerliliğini koruyan
ve hipokrat yemininde
yer alan bu ilkeye göre,
hekim hastasıyla ilgili öğrendiği
bilgileri kimseye açıklamamakla yükümlü.
Bunun gibi; bazı dinlerde din adamlarına
ya da bazı meslek gruplarına,
örneğin avukatlar gibi, getirilmiş
sır saklama yükümlülüklerinin de
geçmişi bir hayli eskiye dayanıyor.
Bununla beraber, bugün anladığımız
anlamda kişisel verilerin korunması
aslında oldukça yeni bir alan.
Bir nevi Sanayi Devriminin çocuğu.
Bugün dünyada üretilen veriler,
korkunç büyüklüklere ulaştı.
2018 yılında, dünyada 33
zetabayt veri üretildi.
Zetabayt nedir derseniz,
1 gigabaytın 1 trilyon katı.
Gözümüzde canlandırmak istersek
157 milyon yıl sürecek
yüksek çözünürlüklü
bir video düşünebilirsiniz.
Nesnel bir karşılaştırma yapmak gerekirse
1 gigabaytı 1 kahve fincanı
olarak düşündüğümüzde,
zetabayt Çin Seddi'nin
toplam hacmine eşit.
Yani 33 tane Çin Seddi'nden bahsediyoruz.
Peki bu kadar çok veri üretiliyorken
bu veriler nerede depolanıyor?
Kim tarafından kullanılıyor?
Kim tarafından işleniyor?
Bunu biliyor muyuz?
Sosyal medya, bugün hemen hepimizin
her anını paylaştığı bir mecra.
Bizler hakkında annemizden,
arkadaşlarımızdan daha çok şey biliyor.
Bunları bilmekle kalmıyor,
bize sürekli bir şeyler
pazarlamaya çalışıyor.
İşte bu sayede,
birkaç gün önce internette
baktığınız güneş gözlüğü
ya da beğenip almadığınız o gömlek,
sizi başka internet sitelerinde de
sürekli takip ediyor.
Düşünün, çok ünlü bir iç çamaşırı
mağazasının internet sitesine girdiniz.
Bir kaç iç çamaşırı baktınız,
almadan çıktınız.
Daha sonra, iş yerinde müdürünüz
beraber bir iş yapmak için masanıza geldi,
bilgisayarınıza oturdu
ve bir internet sitesi açtınız.
İşte o davetkâr
iç çamaşırlar ve sütyenler,
sitenin sağında solunda yanıp sönüyor.
Aslında hepimiz taciz ediliyoruz.
Dijital hayattaki bu uygulamanın
gerçek hayattaki karşılığı;
bir mağazaya girdiniz,
iç çamaşırlarına baktınız
ama almadan çıktınız.
Daha sonra mağaza görevlisinin,
o iç çamaşırını kapıp
evinizin kapısına dayanıp
siz kapıyı her açtığınızda,
o çamaşırı burnunuza dayadığını düşünün.
O mağaza görevlisinin sonunun
çok iyi olmayacağını
sanırım hepimiz tahmin edebiliyoruz.
Sosyal medya, aslında bundan
çok daha fazlasını yapıyor.
Üstelik, biz hiç farkında olmadan.
Facebook'un kurucusu Mark Zuckerberg.
Biz bu fotoğrafı, aslında ülkemizde de
gazetelerde, haberlerde
bir ara çok sıklıkla gördük.
Ama bu beti benzi atmış,
muhtemelen günlerdir
stresten uyuyamamış yüzün
neden Amerikan senatosunun önünde
ifade verdiğini çok da konuşmadık.
Bütün dünyada, çok büyük bir psikolojik
manipülasyon olarak bahsedilen
Cambridge Analytica ve Facebook
vakasından bahsediyorum.
Bu olayda 50 milyon
Facebook kullanıcısının,
ayrıntılı profilleri çıkarılarak
mikro hedefleme yöntemiyle,
doğru zamanda doğru kişinin önüne
doğru içerik çıkarılmak suretiyle,
Amerikan seçimlerinin
Trump lehine manipüle edildiği
artık bütün dünyaca bilinen bir vaka.
Cambridge Analytica yetkilileri,
bir gizli kamera kaydında
insanların farkında olmadıkları,
hatta bilinç altlarında olan
endişeleri, korkuları
ve umutlarını kullanarak
gizlice hedeflenmiş içeriklerin önlerine
çıkarıldığını açıkça anlatıyordu.
Bu olayın etik olmayan
2 unsuru var aslında.
Birincisi, Amerikan seçim yasalarına göre
propoganda bütçesini aşmak yasak.
Cambridge Analytica ise
ürettiği bu bağımsız içerikleri,
bağımsız grupların içerikleriymiş
gibi gösterip bu yasağa dolandı.
İkinci ve daha önemli unsur ise,
seçmenler çoğu zaman
önlerine çıkan bu içeriklerin
siyasi propoganda olduğunun
bile farkında değildi.
Bizler, yetişkin beyinlerimizle
seçim zamanları önlerimize çıkan
propogandaları değerlendirmek,
bunlardan etkilenmek
veya etkilenmemek kararını
bilinçli olarak alabiliyoruz.
Ama bu olayda seçmenler,
belki çok hassas oldukları bir
noktayı etkileyecek bu içeriklerle
farkında olmadan manipüle edildiler.
Bu mikro hedefleme,
öyle bir mikro hedeflemeydi ki
Trump'a oy verme ihtimali bulunduğu
tespit edilen seçmenlerin önüne,
Trump'a oy vermeye yönlendirecek
içerikler çıkarılırken
bu ihtimalin daha düşük
olduğu seçmenlerin önüne,
örneğin Pensilvanya eyaletindeki
siyahi seçmenlerin önüne
sandığa gitmeme, oy vermeme
yönünde içerikler çıkarıldı.
Ulusal güvenlikle ilgili endişeleri
çok yüksek olan seçmenlerin önüne
"Nükleer kodları gerçekten Hillary'e,
üstelik bir kadına mı emanet edeceksiniz?"
şeklinde, hem cinsiyetçi hem
yönlendirici içerikler çıkarıldı.
Seçmenlerin %90'ının yönlendirici
ve yanlış haberler gördüğü
bir seçim düşünün.
Üstelik bu sadece
Amerikan seçimlerinde değil,
Birleşik Krallık'ın, Avrupa Birliği'nden
çıkışına ilişkin Brexit sürecinde,
Kenya seçimlerinde,
Çek Cumhuriyeti, Nijerya
ve hatta Hindistan seçimlerinde de
kullanıldığı söyleniyor.
Yani bütün dünyanın siyasal eğilimini,
aslında kim daha çok para verirse
onun yanında olacak bir
özel şirket yönetmiş.
Peki, siyasi seçimler
bile manipüle edilirken
kararlarınızı gerçekten
siz mi veriyorsunuz?
Ben size, "Facebook'larımızı kapatalım,
Instagram hesaplarımızı kapatalım.
Akıllı cihazlarımızı, akıllı saatlerimizi,
teknolojik bütün ürünleri terk edelim,
doğada tek başımıza yaşayalım," demiyorum.
Ben size mandıra filozofu
olmayı önermiyorum.
Ama bir hukukçu olarak, bunu
sorgulama ihtiyacı hissediyorum.
Siz de soru sorun, sorgulayın,
kararlarınızı bilinçli
şekilde verin istiyorum.
Örneğin, telefonlarınızdaki uygulamaların
hangi kişisel verilerinize
eriştiğini biliyor musunuz?
Hangi uygulamalar fotoğraflarınıza,
videolarınıza, lokasyonunuza,
mikrofonunuza erişiyor?
Ben telefonuma bu gözle baktığımda,
böyle bir tabloyla karşılaştım.
Örneğin, alttan ikinci uygulama
bir döviz uygulaması.
Bir döviz uygulamasının mikrofonuma
erişmeye gerçekten ihtiyacı var mı?
Ya da bu bir ihtiyaçsa bile,
kullanmıyorken bile bu erişimin
devam etmesi gerçekten gerekli mi?
Bütün internet erişimlerimiz,
internette yaptığımız bütün hareketler
işleniyor, depolanıyor
ve bizimle ilgili bilgiler
çıkarılmak üzere kullanılıyor.
Gmail, mail'lerinizi silseniz bile
hatta mail hesabınızı
tamamen yok etseniz bile
bu bilgileri arka planda yedekliyor.
Yine Gmail,
yazdığınız mail'lerin içeriklerini,
evet, mail'lerinizin
içeriklerini kullanıyor.
Gönderdiğiniz, aldığınız
videoları, dökümanları
Youtube videolarının
altına yaptığınız yorumları
bir araya getirip sizi segmente ediyor.
Google'ın Gizlilik Politikası.
11 ayrı sekmeden oluşan,
her sekmede yaklaşık
1600 kelime barındıran,
bu metinler içerisinde başka metinlere
link veren farklı metinler bulunan
bir metinler bütünü.
Benim bir avukat olarak
bu metinler bütününü
okumam iki günümü aldı.
iTunes sözleşmesi de bunun gibiydi.
Fakat gelen tepkiler, talepler üzerine
değiştirildi, sadeleştirildi
ve kısaltıldı.
Yani biz talep etmedikçe
değişmeyecek her şey.
Biz farkında olup talep edince
ancak bir şeyler değişecek.
Çin, daha da ileri giderek
vatandaşlarını skorlamaya başladı.
Bugün, ülkenin bazı
kısımlarında yürülükte olan
ve 2020'de tamamında
yürürlüğe girecek uygulamayla
devlet, hem kamusal alanda
hem dijital alanda
yapılan bütün hareketleri izliyor
ve vatandaşları buna göre skorluyor.
Örneğin, bir ebeveyn çocuğunu iyi
bir okula yazdırmak istediğınde
belki de faturalarını geç ödediği için,
skoru düşük olduğu için, bunu yapamayacak.
Bu distopik bir örnek olsa da
ve çok şükür dünyada henüz
bunu yapan başka ülke olmasa da,
kişisel veri işlemenin aslında nereye
gideceğini gösteren çok çarpıcı bir örnek.
Bütün dünyada bu konular
konuşulmaya, tartışılmaya,
bu konuda düzenlemeler
yapılmaya devam edecek.
Türkiye, 1981 yılında
başka devletlerle beraber
kişisel verilerin korunmasına
ilişkin bir sözleşme imzaladı.
Ama bu sözleşme henüz sadece 3 yıl önce,
2016'da iç hukukumuzda yürürlüğe girdi.
Kişisel Verilerin Korunması Kanunumuz,
yine 2016'da yürürlüğe girdi.
Bunu mukabil, Avrupa Birliği
20 yıldır bu meselelere
kafa yoruyor, düzenlemeler çıkarıyor,
çıkarttığı düzenlemelerin
çağın gerisinde kaldığını görüp
onu iptal edip
yeni düzenlemeler çıkarıyor.
Yani tabiri caizse
onlar maratonda ikinci turu koşarken
biz henüz emekliyoruz.
Bu konuda oldukça liberal olan
Amerika Birleşik Devletleri bile,
yükselen bu hassasiyetlere
önem vermeye başladı.
Yakın zamanda Kaliforniya eyaletinde,
kişisel verilerin korunması
ile ilgili bir düzenleme çıktı.
Mark Zuckerberg ifade verirken
senatör ona, "Dün gece kaldığınız oteli
bizimle paylaşır mısınız?" diye sordu
ve "Hayır," cevabını aldı.
Senatör bunun üzerine,
"İşte esas önemli olan tam da bu;
gizliliğimiz, mahremiyetimiz
ve bunun sınırları
bütün dünyayı birleştirirken
mahremiyetimizden ne kadar
ödün verdiğimiz," dedi.
Hepimize mahremiyetimizden
ödün vermediğimiz,
kararlarımızı bilinçli, özgürce
ve manipüle edilmeden
verdiğimiz bir gelecek diliyorum.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)